hey everybody it's pete holmes and matt
mccarthy from the pete holm show here to
give you some super bowl tips because
matt is a super bowl party expert
welcome matt thank you pete you get it
what welcome welcome matt
welcome wipe your feet on it did you
wipe your feet on the welcome mat tell
them some of your tips matt right off
the bat the most important thing for
your super bowl party like right like a
football analogy right off right out of
the quarterback's hand
um
with spin
right out of the snap
first thing you need for your super bowl
party booze
what you need is booze at your party get
yourself a nice cooler get a few beers
not the healthiest choice alcohol's a
toxin it's a super bowl you got to drink
booze i guess
instead how about something that's
actually good for your body like
kombucha this isn't a weird confusing
signal to send to your liver on a sunday
afternoon this is something that your
body will thank you for
there's no booze in that actually there
is it's 0.5 alcohol at a whole foods
they will card you
okay so you got no booze well 0.5 is a
little bit just enough some would say so
snacks
very important for your super bowl party
chips and dips uh pizza hot wings the
hotter the better those don't really
sound like heart-healthy options
you know it's the ceo of your whole body
so you got to keep them happy and i
don't think he said bring me some wings
okay well it's just one day yeah but you
know what they say uh buffalo wing today
full buffalo chicken tomorrow nobody
says it's a gateway poultry
it's not a thing it is a thing why not
something more whole a kale a lot of
vitamin k good for your skin like these
would be good to put your hot wings on
so the sauce doesn't know look we're
coming back to the earth it's what we
call a whole food
okay
you got no booze you got no snacks a
little bit of booze
the most important thing for the super
bowl sunday party is the tv
i think it's the people
connection big screen saying it's more
about the community high definition no
maybe play it on the radio quietly so
you can have more interesting
conversations rather than rooting for a
team you have no control over no no it's
it's super bowl sunday
watch the game does it have to be on
sunday yes the game is on sunday it's
super bowl sunday i don't really like
having a big party on a sunday because
on monday you're grumpy and less
productive i say super bowl saturday and
then move the super bowl to saturday we
have to get all worked up blood vessels
popping go seahawks are they playing
is it the seahawks
lions is it the all right you know what
this is you're you're out of [__]
mind okay you guys [__] super bowl
saturday yeah with kale yeah and
kombucha
you know what
enjoy your freak show super bowl
saturday party i'm out i'm gonna go
watch football with the rest of america
he's a fun time at the movies
i'd love to sketch him